We have only so far been able to touch on the very basic concepts
of designing intelligent search trees.
And research to date is much more advanced.
So you might be wondering, considering the state of the art, how low can you go?
What are the best search tree algorithms to date that we know of?
Actually, I'm not going to tell you anything about vertex cover for now
because that problem will deserve a little more attention later in this unit.
I will show you the state of the art for some other problems.
So for independent set there are currently 2 algorithms
that could kind of be considered to be the smallest search trees.
One has size 1.189 to the power of N,
and the other one has size 1.211 to the power of N.
It's 2 different algorithms.
This here has a bit larger search tree, but the algorithm itself is probably a little bit faster
in the worst case than this one here because of the polynomial factors that are involved.
But this here is just the search tree size.
For clique it's the same as independent set, as always,
because of the close connectedness of those 2 problems.
In one of the previous units you also got to know 3 SAT,
which is a satisfiability problem where every clause has exactly 3 variables,
and that can be solved with a search tree of 1.496 to the power of N last time I checked.
This is a very advanced search tree.
It's basically half a book of proofs required to show this here.
Now, what about shortest tour or, more generally, the traveling salesman problem,
which is shortest tour, only that you can only visit a city exactly once.
This is a very interesting one because the best--
well, it's not even really a search tree--but the best algorithm has an exponential factor
of 2 to the power of N.
So here it's still an open research problem to find out
if you can design better search algorithms for this problem.
By the way, in case you're wondering, do the laws of NP completeness,
as far as we know them, say anything about how low the exponent can go,
so really put a limit on the space here?
Say, for example, unless P equals NP, there is no algorithm for independent set
with a search tree that is smaller than 1.1 to the power of N or something like that.
And the answer here is we don't know.
So it might be that you can solve independent set, for example,
in an algorithm with 1.01 to the power of N as your search tree size.
Nothing in the laws of NP completeness that would speak against that.